Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Minotaur
Now this is a point and click, puzzle-adventure game
But this is just an early phase demo.
It's a.... I don't know, it seems to have a lot of really nice art, so i'm gonna play as "Nod" here.
M: So Nod....
(Ollie: Mister Pikes?)
M: Hi... My name is Nod! Call me Nod. Excuse me.
(Ollie: Mister Pikes...!)
M: It's Nod.
(Ollie:NOD!)
M:There we go. I'm awake now.
I didn't know that was gonna happen (giggling).
( Nod: Oh...My head. My head hurts) M: Maybe it's all the wires going into your brain there.
( Ollie: Of couse it does. Ugh, you slept for too long and you still reek of booze)
M: Uh... Don't ..(laughing) I...I can't drink it, you know that! I have to rub it all over my body!
It's the only way i can get a high!
( Nod: How can you tell Ollie? I never installed any smell receptors)
Uh~~ (Ollie: They're called offactory receptors... And I don't need to smell, I can practically see it.)
M: that doesn't make any sense at all
(Ollie: Anyway, you have to pull yourself together and head out. Your nightshift at the factory starts in half an hour) M: Okay. What does that mean?
( Nod: OH CRAP!)
M (Mimicking) : Oh Crap!
(Nod: Why don't you wake me up earlier?!)
M: Uh, I don't....Yeah! Why you no not Nod wake up?!
(Ollie: By my calculations, 30 minutes is just enough)
M: Oh, kay', sure yeah, okay.
(Ollie: Just...barely enough...)
( Mark's gorgeous laugh): I'm so glad i made a.. anime robot with a "sass".
( Nod: You really need some tuning, Ollie)
M: Alright (Nod: But you're right, i have to get going...or my boss will never get off my ass) M: hmm~ kinky, alright, let's go to it!
So~~ in game menu ( click on the calendar) sweet calendar.
( Nod: I remember taking those photos of Irene in our local club, " Demon's armpit", just three years ago.
M: T..( burst out giggling) The ..demon's " armpit" ?! That's the name of your local club?! Oh a successful club,  is it?
(Nod: And now, look at her. Performing on the stage of Supernova)
M: Ah, Supernova, a much better name for a club
( Nod: i guess i should be happy for her) M: uh~
( Ollie: Wow...it's yesterday all over again)M: uh~okay, drinking to forget the past where these, to this.. These don't make any sense! Bash?! What is that?
( Nod: that's one of two alignment days, it's a very significant day)
( Ollie & Nod: A day off) M: wait, hang..
(Nod: That's one of two alignment days, when Hades and Logan, both our stars, rise up and go down at the same time) M: okay
( Nod: it's a very sign...[& Ollie]: A day off!)
M: Alright, cool. Do you have any informations about every single one of these days? Or do i have to find the red ones?
M: Alright, whatever, okay. I'll see what else we've got. Balcony door. Ah
(Nod:Not the best view in Nova, but at least I can't hear Ollie from here) M: ugh, gross
M: Everything's horrible ( a train runs by) Whoosh!
(Nod: I think that was the last train for today)
M: Yay! I don't have to go to work, i think. Does that... is that what's that means? (Nod: Nobody knows why Demons never attack trains)
M: Demons? You say (Nod: But... don't look a gift horse in the mouth!) ( Confused Mark)
( Nod: Thanks to that phenomenon, trains are the only way to move safely between dome cities) M: DEMONS?! Dome cities? Oh~
( Nod: Axis domes have shielded us from demons for almost 5 centuries) M: Demons?
( Nod: I don't remember the name of the woman who invented them, but we all owe her our lives)
M: It's like the Final Fantasy movie
M: uh, it's super weird. okay. Oh, He who brings Plague?! (Nod:Plague...huh...nasty) M: hmm...( Nod: i heard this Demon recently became active in parts around Nova)
(Nod: Just look at Him.. I could never understand who go outside domes willingly)M: Bunch of freaks lookin' for freedom in what not and what have you! Not for me!
( Nod: The picture looks kinda...blurry. And glitchy) M: Not for me, not at all! Never actuallly! Uh.. ( Ollie: It's always been like that)
M: Right (Ollie: You bought the cheapest data panel on the market... And the used one, too!)
M: uhm.. that would be probably imply that was a cheapest. (Nod :no, that's not it. I think something's wrong with our Axis power grid)
M: hmmmm....( Nod: Maybe i should turn the panel off, just in case) M: Okay ( turned the TV off) Ulp..did that! Alright, what do we got here? Is that a gun?
(Ollie: So, Mister Pikes, any words on that outfitter's license?)
(Nod:  I'm working on it Ollie. You know it's expensive.)
M: *Blabbers incoherently* (Ollie: How do you even manage to find clients for weapon enhancements without the permit?)
(Nod: Ha Ha... I'm just that good, I guess?) M: Yeah okaay
(Ollie: Yeah, and I guess all of your clients have special reasons to work with someone who doesn't keep official records.)
Mark: Uh huh, ok
(Nod: "Sole witness") M: Yeesh (Nod: PHG-12 particle handgun) M:I love the backgrounds in this, like the artWork is reeealy nice, and everythings animated.
(Nod: It's almost completely silent, but lacks firepower. And i'm supposed to take care of that.) M: OK
Mark: You need a loud KABOOMER on it. Theres your problem, it's not loud enough!
Mark: Everyone knows lethality's compare to loudness. Ok.
Mark: Ahh!
Mark: OoOo!
Mark: Items are used automatigically. Ok, what does that have to do with what I'm doing here, though?
(Nod: Wait a second... I feel like I'm forgetting something.)
M: Aw yeah! The gun! Not for.. ah
Mark: Don't make a medajoke in here! What am i doin'?
(Nod: Maybe I should take a closer look at those triangular nodes on the left before leaving...)
Mark: Maybe I should!
Mark: Mayybe I'll do that! Nod think Nod had a good idea..
(Nod: Aha! Thats it! The invisible hand never lies!)
Mark: Uh huh... Yeah, what about that?
*Magic noise*
Mark: Are you the invisible hand or am I the invisible hand, because..
frankly you're talking to yourself about an invisible hand that gave yourself a suggestion
so you think that that's what's guiding you through this adventure.
*takes deep breath*
Mark: Alright, I'm outta here!
Mark: I'm gonna figure out what the hell with eevverything else going on.
Mark: * Sings doodly-doo* Can I leave?
*Electricity buzzes*
Mark: *Disgusted* Ooo, that looks baad!
Mark: BOOP!
Mark: Boop Bodoop, BEE
*Phone rings*
(Nod: Ollie, come on... Just tell me the code.)
Mark: It's probably the two adman days!
(Ollie: you know i can't, Mister Pikes.)
Mark: Ouuh...
(Ollie: I'm sure you used SOMETHING to make your code up.)
Ollie: You're not very good at starting from scratch!)
(Ollie: And I mean that on soo many levels.)
Mark: Eeeey! That's ruude!
Mark: You're RUUUDE!
Mark: RUUUUDE!!!
Mark: I know what it is...
Mark: It's probably these days.
Mark: So it's 2-0-1-8
Mark: I bet thats it: 2-0-1-8.
Mark: 2018.
Mark: Two, zero, one, eight
*phone rings*
(Ollie: You do realize there are ten thousand possible combinations, Mister Pikes?)
Mark: I know that!
(Ollie:  This could take a while...)
Mark: How 'bout you stop laughing at me and be useful, Ya DAMN robot!
(Nod: My good old D12 storage unit.)
Mark: A D12 you say?
(Nod: It's empty... and they almost talked me into buying a D24!)
Mark muttering sarcastically: Haha! Those scoundrels! Those scoundrels!
(Nod: Ugh....)
(Nod: I can't even look at that right now.)
Mark: What about some of the hair the dog- the bel- th- You know the saying! The hair dog biting!
That thing?
Remember that?
Mark: Can I use that on anything?
Mark: Bwep!
Mark: ahhhhhh
Ohhhhhhh
Oooooooooo
Mark: Right, so what did that do?
Can I leave?
(Ollie: Mister Pikes.)
(Nod: I don't like where this is going, but... Yes?)
(Ollie: Do you want me to call the police?)
Mark: What?!
frankly you're talking to yourself about an invisible hand that gave yourself a suggestion
so you think that that's what's guiding you through this adventure.
( Ollie: NOD!)
M: There we go! I'm awake now ( giggling)
M: Maybe it's all the wires going into your brain there.
( Ollie: Of course it does. Ugh, you slept for so long and you still reek of booze)
M: That doesn't make any sense at all.
(Nod: That's one of two alignment days, when Hades and Logan, both our stars, rise up and go down at the same time) M: okay
Or do I have to find the red ones?
(Nod:Not the best view in Nova, but at least I can't hear Ollie from here) M: ugh, gross
( Nod: Axis domes have shielded us from demons for almost 5 centuries) M: Demons?
(Nod: Please let me out.)
(Ollie: No can do... Security protocol and all that.)
Mark: Uh-huh.
(Nod: Come on, Ollie, you know I'm already late for work. Please?)
(Ollie: Let me think... No. Please disable the alarm first, Mister Pikes, or I'll have to call the police.)
Mark: Damn robots!
(Ollie: Who knows what they'll say about that little outfitting shop you run here?)
Mark: Ooooh, like you wouldn't get confiscated too!
(Nod: Not much of an "assistant", are you?)
Mark: Damn you!
(Ollie: Hey, I am. You can always ask me for advice. I can't tell you the code, but I can help you figure it out.)
Mark: Okaay, how do you do that?
(Ollie: You can just tell me if you miss me, Mister Pikes.)
Mark: Well I'm j- I'm just saying!
(Nod: I really don't.)
(O: Let's look for something that holds sentimental value.)
M: Ahh.
(O: In your life, that's mostly your ex.)
M: Hey, shut up about me and my personal problems!
You leave me and me alone!
M: Irene.....
(O: Mister Pikes, do you know what "moving on" means?)
M: Shut up.
(O: You should try it sometime.)
M: Shut UP. Sassy robot...
That's not.. cool.
That's weird.
That's some good advice! Not not going to listen to you!
Not going to drink away Nod's sorrows and shut you up later as soon as I remember the code.
Uh huh. Yeah.
Yyynever.
Yeah, tomorrow, how about tomorrow, that's also good.
Well, I'll click on this old- whooa~
Hey hey hey heeey I got a screwdriver for this.
Bwamp! Hahaha. *reading* Strange journey.
Yeah. In.. Yes 23.
Probably you'll ever have; not ain't gonna have better days than I- when than when I had with my ex
That's how sad I am.
Hahaha...
Strange journey, yes 23.
Okay, so I gotta look for uh..
I know what I need to do!
Is 'Yes' one of these weird- 'Jeeees', twenty threee!
Twenty one- nooo.
That.. mm.. 'ZN'.
'ZN 23'?
Well this is the se- six, so.. 0623?
0623 could it be 0623?
Could it be uh.. 0-6-2...
*beep* Yaay!
No you're not, shut up.
Like I said preemptively: shut up.
*mocking* Yeah, blah blah blah blah babble brabble well I yell at my computer too.
Haha, right, who runs in this time?
Uh, okay.
What the Hades?
Nod no understand what that is?!
Ooh, 'The Day Before'...
Okay, what's happening the day before?
Ehh...
Shut up ex of mine that I love.
Hey, Irene.
'Noddy'. *laughs* Didn't know my name was Noddy.
Ah.
Yeah, true.
Good thing you gave context of the sentence that came prior before that
or else we wouldn't have any idea what was happening.
Uh huh.
Suure, is it about how you love me and miss me?
Thanks, cool, it's squalor in there anyway, you wouldn't want to see it.
I'll just cry about it later.
Mmnope, let's not do that, that sounds depressing.
*mocking* Demon's armpit.
*hums*
Uh huh.
Yeah.
Ahh...
Mhm.
Yeah, like friends. You know how friends piggy-back on each others' backs all the time.
And then piggy-front later in the hotel.
You know. You remember.
You remember?
That's ridiculous, I love that photo
I look at it every night right before I go to bed.
Alright.
Oh thanks, Ollie, for your un-needed help
your unwavering support is such bullshit.
Shut up, Ollie!
I can handle this and my emotions.
Maturely.
Oh, Arthur..
Is that Arthur?
*mimicking* Ahh, Irene! I like this guy.
*Mimics* Nod. Arthur. *giggling*
Well, well if you say so.
Oooh.
*high pitched* mm, let's go?
Uh huh.
*sighing* uh huh.
*mocking* Bye, Irene. Ugh.
Pbbtt, time to get drunk.
Uh, I wonder why. *giggling*
Well, something tells me that maybe the
the relationship falling apart wasn't entirely Arthur in this.. endeavor.
Oh. Ooh, look at that.
Ooo, aah, look at her! That's great.
Oh, wowie-zowie, yep.
*laughing* Like I said, look at it every night right before I go to bed
and Ollie is always there watching and judging how creepy I am and how I can't move on.
Oo, robo. Is that Arthur?
Ah. OOh! Pengu?
What are you doing there? Is that a guitar?
That's awesome, that's an awesome penguin.
Ah, this looks so cool!
I don't think the full game is out, though.
Like I'm pretty sure this is just a- whoaah.
Heey, okay.
That's the name of the game.
Okay, there you have it.
That, anyway.
Ooo, chapter 2, I didn't even know there was going to be a chapter 2.
Oh well sweet dickens dabie-doh.
No it is not, sir.
No.
Uh huh.
I dunno, you were really drunk.
Yeah, see, the guiding hand knows what's-
Euuhh, speaking of guiding hand, holy shit.
Shit.
That's my only concern.
The waste of human life means nothing, so long as it's not Irene!
Yeah, it's definitely not Irene.
This poor, unsuspecting person under a pile of rubble.
Whew, that's a load off my mind.
Oh, Maya, who's Maya?
Yeah, okay. Yeah best not to tell anyone about it either.
Yeah, no joke.
*mocking* Neh-neh bulldozer.. Arthur's a bulldozer.
*mumble* if you know what I mean.
Alright fine then, what are we supposed to do about this?
Ollie!
Ollie (x7) help.
Ollie (x5) help.
So let's just barge right in.
Maya, boo! Nod's here!
Nod's home!
Hmm.
Yeah, not crushed under that pile.
Don't mind if I just.. go in your home.
Yeah, I'm such a champ.
Eh, is that a euphemism?
Yeah, seems like a fair exchange.
Oh, bonsai.
Alright, fine, does everything cool freak you out?
Yeah, unnatural about that, says the guy with a robo arm and a robo neck.
Bleh, bleh bleh, oh shut up about Irene.
Nod, get over it.
What do we got here?
Uh huh.
Uh huh. Can I ruin it?
Oh, can I ruin it?
Oh, *laughing* can I ruin it?
OooOOOoo!
Ooo.
Ah.
Yeah, probably.
Best to just take her stuff.
*spritz*
*giggling*
Ahhh, I shouldn't be doing this.
Why am I just messing with someone else's painting?
Mmnah, I'm gonna keep doing this.
Let's go for that sweet sand.
Can I make- can I make her beige?
*markimoo noises* Boom!
*spritz*
Haha!
Take that!
*laughing* That was wrooong!
For no reason!
That.. nothing.. is weird about that.
Ah, that would have been weirder!
But I'm.. For no reason!
Just, haha, paint's in the wrong place.
Is it good is it bad?
Yup.
Let's just uh.. forget anything happened here
move on with our lives,
everybody just delete that from your brain, what just happened there
and uh, we'll just carry on!
Like nothing happened.
Cuz nothing did.
Ah- ooo, sunny!
Ooo, Hades and Logan.
Ahh.
*Reads last sentence* Ooo.
Alrighty then.
'Bars control'... oh!
let me just steal her car
Why not, I've taken everything else. I'll be right back hang on.
Gotta make sure that I got everything.
Aquaman?
What?
What is- *stuttering*
You want to run that by me again?
Uh huh.
Okay, alright, everything always leads back to Marine M- Irene a little bit.
Noo! Kick back, relax, have a drink.
Hm.
*whisper* with your baby?
With Irene's baby??
Alright, where's this lock-box he was talking about?
What are we looking for?
Where are we going? Barrels?
Barrels?
Yeah sure okay.
Okay alright well that's good I guess?
I dunno.
Why not?
Not like there's a dead body behind me.
Sure okay I don't know what that is.
Yeah?
Uh huh.
Uh huh. Okay. What does these notes mean?
I don't even know what I'm rooting power to.
But it seems like a car is there so I guess I couldn't have driven the car without it.
Oooo..
Oh let's get a... ooo...
Ahh...
*click*
Huh. Well that one's burnt out right there so...
I guess there's no going for that.
Ahhhh, I think I know...
I know, I think I get it...
*clinking and clicks*
Ahhh!
Oh I had to push the button for the overlay, I didnt...
*laughing* I didn't..
Ahhh, I was here fuddlin' with it for like, 10 minutes
and I was like "I don't get this, this doesn't make any sense,
this overlay wasn't as good as this boss thought he said he did!"
Alright, so
Ahhh.
Okay.
I think I understand what's going on here.
I think I got a..
an a.. an inklink.
Okay.
Ah.
Oo, yeah, oh that's the right stuff.
Oh that's the good stuff.
Oh that's good stuff!
Oh that's good stuff alright.
*powering up sound* Ahhh! There's one thing!
Alright, so I don't know what the teeth coming out of the demon is
but I'm gonna go find out what the
the teeth in the demon thing is all about.
Ooooh, so that would have been over there.
Uh, I can't get through there. Okay, so that's not going to help me at all for some reason
and I don't think i can do the other thing
because it's all rusted away-
No it's not. Oh.
No it's not, oh! *kiss*
Heeey!
What station?
What station did I just power up?
I don't know what I- Ooo.
Do I need to go get the- ooOOo
Do I need to go get like a power cell from the thing?
Ow.
Okay well whatever.
How 'bout the hovercar?
Ah
*ding*
I already know!
Ugh..
NO!
Uh huh. What are you, my girlfriend?
Don't be my girlfriend.
Mhm.
Thanks, Ollie, you're so nice.
*hums*
Ahhhhhhh, I found something!
I don't know what I found but I found it.
That's what I just asked, Nod!
Could you get your head out of your ass and stop talking to Ollie that way?
Thank you Ollie.
Yeah, well maybe you shouldn't have asked it, Nooood.
Name's NOD.
I am talking to a virtual reality assistant, so.. eh.
Hmm.
Yeah, better hold onto this useless junk that I'm stealing from Maya!
Uh oh!
Ah, so hence why the thing over in the thing-thonger
and the-the-the free leach of power doo-dadder that I got.
Also that dead body! Still there!
Still there.
I don't know, what are you talkin' about?
*beeping* WooooO!
Yay!
Yaay!
Yay! Also, still forgetting:
Dead body! Right there! Right there on the ground.
Its blood is oozing towards me and I'm worried about getting to work.
Why haven't I called the police?
Oh yeah, because my apartment is full of gun.
Alright whatever anyway I'm angry for no reason.
I'm not even angry. What, do you think I'm angry?
I'm not angry. What are you talking about?
Turn on blue vision!
Alright I gotta get this over to the other thing so that I can go I think
there was something about a car there so I'm only assuming that that's..
what that is..
How do I.. Oh, this one's a puzzle.
Bam!
Aww, what, why no bam-
Oooh, cuz it not right way.
Well how you make that not...
Ooooohhh why you no not right way...
Oh wait I'm dumb, what am I doing, why didn't I just
Oh, I didn't even realize I had two of those, oh god I'm so stupid.
I just- oh god.
Aaahh, the pump charger, that I didn't even look at but it took me forever to get
Turn off blue vision!
Alright, Maya.
Hope you don't mind me going through your place once more.
Alright, I got her hovercar.
Ollie, let's go.
Okay.
*beeping*
*markisniff*
Yay!
That seems bad.
Okay! Honk honk.
Ha-yes!
Awww.
Uughh.
Damn you, you pregnant lady.
I'm gonna be mad at you and mess with your painting some more.
*mumble* Yeah, I think I understand this.
Hm.
Yeah.
Well, good thing I just connected that, now didn't I?
Okay! Well I literally just did that, so
Brrt. Brrt.
Ah! Ooooo
Yeah, don't need to wait for it to charge or anything.
You shouldn't do that.
(Nod humming)
*singing* I heard some cash was saved and I am not over my ex~!
Blah de be blah- Ooooo.
How 'bout that dead body while you were humming about not dead bodies, huh?
You ever think about that for one god- ooooooo
Heh.
How did Ollie not hear that. That was a frickin explosion.
Also!
D-dead body!
*sigh*
Yeah, oh no.
Alright, well.
Time to go I guess?
Or do I need to- What do I need to do?
I for- I've forgotten what you actually needed to do
I was too worried about the dead body.
Yes I did. The guiding hand says yes.
Okay so what-
Oooo what is.. going on there, I don't.. somethin's blue..
Oh. Maya!
Probably should have asked that before I barged in and messed with your painting.
Mmm
Yeah you didn't hear that explosion or the hallway collapsing?
Cuz that's, yknow..
That's a thing.
That happened.
Yeah she does.
What shape does she keep herself in?
Heh. Good joke, me.
Alright anyway.
Bars. No bars?
Inner district?
Ah.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
They don't have their girlfriends leave them for Arthurs!
Aahhh, Nod's sad!
Alright. Ollie. Help. Help, help me.
I don't know. But here we go.
Can we go? Did-de-boof.
Leagues?
Ahh.
Are you just talking to yourself or are you hoping somebody else hears you?
Aww, no, never.
A-broom!
*ding*
Ha, made it. Nailed it.
I'm gonna assume that's not a euphemism.
*chuckle*
Ooooh, thanks, Ollie.
For nothing.
Alright, let's get out of here. Purgatory?
Hello?
"You made it-
so far, this is my room."
"This is where my story begins."
Awwww! Noo, this is where the demo ends!
Ahhhhh!
I was into it! I was so into it.
The adventures of Nod.
Awww..
"Just click this button, come on, do it. Hurry."
Oh, geez. Hey, calm down there.
Ooo, I don't know if I want to click that.
Okay, well I guess that's the end of the demo.
So thank you everybody so much for watching- whoa.
*laughing as he reads it*
I'm pretty fucked up!
*reading aloud*
Aalrighty then.
There ya have it, there's some extras in there..
That's really cool, that is really cool.
I liked that a lot. So.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below
and I actually am very much looking forward to a full release of this game
It was very exposition-a-ful
in the demo, obviously, but
it did set a good tone to it, like
when I was looking at the screenshots for this game-
Get outta my fuckin hair..
When I was looking at the screenshots for this game I wasn't too sure about it
But now that I've played it, like it's one of those things that you have to play to really get the feel of it
and I really do appreciate so
thank you again
let me know what you think
and as always,
I will see you. In the next video!
Buh-bye!
*outro music*